- [Instructor] The idea
of genetic engineering
is something that we associate
with the 20th century.
We didn't even know
that genes were actually
the mechanism of heredity
until the middle of the 20th century.
And the direct modification
of genes for some purpose
really didn't even start
happening until the 1970s.
But it's worth noting that human beings
have been, in some ways,
influencing the genetics
of organisms for a very,
very, very long time.
For example, in nature you have
things that look like this.
We call them wolves.
But today in our lives,
we also have things that look like this.
Now these dogs did not
come about naturally.
They came about from many
generations of breeding,
of human beings taking things
that started off looking
like wolves or foxes,
and selecting for certain traits.
They might have selected for traits
that maybe they're small, and
they look more like puppies,
even when they're full grown.
Or traits that they are more docile.
They're more likely to listen
to what a human being says to do.
Or traits that they're
good at killing rodents,
or whatever else it might be,
and over time, repeated
selection of those traits
led to what we see as these
different breeds of dogs.
So even though human
beings were doing this
for hundreds and thousands of years,
they were influencing
what DNA gets passed on
from one generation to another.
They didn't know about
the actual genetic code,
but it was a form of genetic
manipulation nonetheless.
Similarly, if you look
into the plant kingdom,
when you go to the store and
you see that sweet apple,
things like that might not have existed
in the form that you see them today.
It is very likely, in fact
most agricultural products,
people might have found wild apples,
and we could be talking
thousands of years ago.
They might have found wild apple trees.
Let me draw a quick apple tree here.
And they might've found
that the apples were a little bit sour,
and small, and hard to
eat, and hard to digest,
but over time, people selected the trees
that had sweeter apples,
that had larger apples,
and made the conditions
so that they were more
likely to reproduce.
So over time, you got
larger and sweeter apples
like the type that you see at your store.
And as I mentioned,
most agricultural products
that we have today
are the result of hundreds
or thousands of years
of this type of breeding.
So even though that might
not be the formal definition
of genetic engineering,
which typically is referring
to something like gene modification,
which we've only been able to
do in the last few decades,
human beings have been
doing some type of influence
on organisms' DNA for
a very, very long time.
But with that said, in
the last few decades,
we've been able to become
much, much more precise
with influencing DNA
through genetic engineering.
In other videos,
we'll go more detail
about how that is done,
but you have this idea of recombinant DNA,
where you could take
genes from one organism
and put them in another organism.
And you might say, why is this useful?
Well let's say there is
a tree you wanna grow.
Let's say it's an apple tree,
but it's very susceptible to
a certain type of disease,
and if that disease hits,
you lose all of your crop.
But what if you could insert
into the DNA of that apple tree
maybe a gene that makes it
more resistant to that disease?
And this is what people actually do today.
So they will insert DNA,
and it could be from
some pretty wild things.
I've read stories about
inserting insect DNA into a plant
so that it will be more
robust in some way or another.
Now this idea of recombinant DNA
and genetically modifying food,
this is often known as a
genetically modified organism,
this is somewhat controversial.
Many people say, hey this is good.
It allows us to produce more robust foods.
In fact, part of this recombinant DNA,
inserting DNA into something else,
it might make it more nutritious.
It might provide for more vitamins.
But other people would argue that,
hey we don't know exactly
what all the repercussions
of what we're doing will happen.
We might think it's helpful,
but when you're taking
DNA from one organism
and putting it into another,
how does that affect the nutrition,
or the long-lasting effects
of eating that over time?
So this is something
for you to think about.
And we're starting to go,
when we start asking these questions,
into the field of bioethics.
As we have more and more
control over the genome,
and especially, as we'll
see, the human genome,
there's questions that we have to ask
about is it good, or is it bad?
But going back to this
idea of genetic engineering
and recombinant DNA,
other things that you
could do is you could,
let's say that we need to
produce insulin for diabetics.
Well, maybe you can take a bacteria cell,
and insert into the bacteria cell
the gene that helps produce for insulin.
And then, all of a sudden,
that bacteria cell can become
an human-insulin-producing factory,
so that we could have more
insulin for diabetics,
that this insulin could then be harvested.
That is a use of recombinant DNA.
And so we really are going into
an interesting period in humanity.
For many thousands of years
we were breeding things,
but now we're learning
to manipulate things
at a very fine-grain level.
And it makes us ask
all sorts of questions.
There are likely to be some
very good things we can do.
Produce new medicines.
Produce more robust crops.
But there are also questions about
what are the side effects?
And the bioethics get really
interesting when we start
thinking about modifying
the human genome itself.
Because when you're modifying genetics,
you're not just modifying one organism,
you're modifying all of their offspring.
You're modifying the genes
that exist in the gene pool.
And so some very good arguments
for modifying the human genome are
correcting diseases, some things
that could be very serious.
But over time, things might,
people might say, hey I
wanna be a little bit taller,
or I want a certain hair color,
or I want straighter teeth.
Or they might say,
I want a child who has
this trait or that trait.
So things get very, very interesting
the more we think about how
genetic engineering may be used.